god damn it
we're like sherpas on top of [ __ ] i
know i was like dude i'm not a [ __ ]
sherpa what the [ __ ] is going on it's
the 21st [ __ ] century
and look the [ __ ] is still like blinking
it's going like it's
going like green yellow orange
green yellow orange it might just be
this might just be that it's
fished i mean no it was it's spell check
doing that i said i [ __ ] it
he meant [ __ ] time
god why is it like the watches why
tomorrow right we split stream tomorrow
no okay wednesday because tomorrow's
thanksgiving day okay that's it we'll
see we'll see on friday right tomorrow
we're gonna see on friday hey we're
still on we're on we're on it's green
how did it go green
because who [ __ ] knows i don't know
what [ __ ] is up with this [ __ ] i don't
know
okay it's red again
just end it yeah well like i said
at least we talked about some [ __ ]
yes
i didn't get in all the stuff but i kind
of expected that yeah so
say goodbye
uh so yeah everybody have a happy
thanksgiving i'm gonna get up early
tomorrow hopefully and put on the
[ __ ] they can't hear you
what
i'm waiting for it to come back on okay
it's kind of going from red to orange
maybe yeah
come on
i just shut it down it's over
okay nope
i gotta do it
you
oh now we're back on
jesus christ why
i don't know tom already left because he
was just kind of like you know [ __ ] it
and honestly
whatever i'm just like i don't even have
the patience board at this point
oh this is so
so upsetting all right
so i mean i guess you know we've been
going for like [ __ ] however long it
was almost four hours
so happy thanksgiving everybody hope you
have a good one if you celebrate it if
you're in another country and you don't
whatever doesn't matter have a good day
tomorrow anyway
and uh we will see you guys on
[ __ ] we will see you guys on friday
uh doing our side track show
and uh we'll tell you how thanksgiving
went
so until then